(instrumental music)
- My mom had just taken me
on this great shopping spree
for my birthday, and I
bought these clothes.
I walked into the lunch room,
and everyone made so much fun of me.
I felt so ashamed, the
fact that I was different.
There are just so many specifics
that have stuck with me
to this day that have
really instilled the sense
of, like, fear.
- I had a Pocahontas backpack,
and I loved that Pocahontas backpack.
I wore it to school and got ripped,
and everyone made fun of me.
It just became a routine
where I would come home
from elementary school crying.
- I was teased growing up for being gay
before I even knew that I was gay.
Fourth grade, only played
with girls at recess,
and my teacher took me out of class
and talked to me and was like,
"You should really hang out
with other boys sometimes."
And I remember being like,
"Why are you telling me
"who I should hang out with
and why does it matter?"
- Growing up in elementary, I
always hung out with the girls
but I did actually like them at that time.
I had a crush on like almost every girl
at the table I sat with at one point.
They're like, oh I just
see you as a friend.
- (laughing) Awe. That's
the saddest thing.
- But I remember the jock
guys always telling me like,
oh you're gay, and like, (bleeping) gay,
and people making fun of me not only
cause they assumed I was gay,
but because I was overweight.
- I was asked, growing up, like if I was,
and I was like, oh my god,
are they going to find out?
Growing up, you hear stories
about gay people getting
killed on the street.
- And that like happens still now.
- Yeah
- Which is horrifying.
- I was bullied in middle school
by somebody who eventually came out,
and he would bully me for being gay
which was him projecting
onto me his insecurities.
- I think being bullied
for being gay just kind
of confirmed that I didn't
want to come out of the closet.
I was afraid of coming out
and admitting to myself,
and to the world, like who I really am.
- I don't know if that
kind of trickled down
into like my adulthood.
Now, I am sure it has cause
everything that we experience
in our lives like affects
us in one way or another.
(light instrumental music)
- I don't show PDA when I'm on the street,
like I don't hold hands.
I'm afraid that society
is going to regress,
and then all of a sudden there's gonna
to be laws about being gay.
- Gay people are getting shot,
gay people are getting, like, attacked.
Oh, it's okay to hate
people who aren't like you.
I definitely do feel like
already a shift back.
I still haven't let it
overwhelm me with fear yet,
but it is like this
little thing nagging me
in the back of my head, like,
"Is it still okay for you
to be yourself all the time?
"Are you going to getting
a rock thrown at your head
"if you like hold your boyfriend's hand?"
- I think for me the
biggest fear that I have is
that the younger generation
kind of coming up people
in their teens and 20s
have had it pretty good,
like, they've seen so much
change in the past 10 years,
and where being gay is very
accepted and almost a norm
in society, and they don't
know how hard it has been
to fight for those things.
Some of those rights
can still be taken away.
- And they are, even me,
like, the difference,
I know it's not a big age
difference, but there's a lot
of very privileged gay
kids growing up now.
You could literally tell them,
"Oh, well this person
helped with this movement."
And they'll be like, "Oh I
don't care, blah, blah, blah."
And ya know, they should
because that's the reason why
they can be so IDGAF on Instagram
and, I don't care haters,
and this and that,
because of people like that
that have fought for me.
- For me, especially, it felt like,
you're not accepted, you're
gay, you're gay, you're gay,
and then all the sudden,
wow, gays can get married,
it's cool again.
We forget about the middle of the country,
and the students out there
who can't be protected,
and I think that there's
still a lot of work to do,
starting to be more mindful of the laws
that protect people like me
and little kids out there who need it.
(ambient music)
- I think when I first
came out, I was like,
"Oh yeah, it would be a lot
easier if I were straight."
- I have never wished I was straight.
- I remember going to sleep
sometimes, and being like,
"Oh, man, I wish I was straight,
I wish I was straight."
And then crying and
everything, it was intense.
- When I met my current boyfriend,
I told him that one day
I would marry a girl
cause at the time I was not out at all,
and that's what I thought I had to do.
That's what society tells you,
please my parents, deny
a big part of myself.
Now I love being gay
because that's who I am.
- No, no I never wished
I was straight, never.
- I absolutely did wish I was straight.
I thought, when I was younger,
that being gay would mean
a life of more bullying.
- As much bullying as I went through,
and had to like endure, being
gay has become something
that I am so, so, so proud of.
- But once you like rip that Band-Aid off,
you're out, no I wouldn't change a thing.
- You come out of the closet
and you just seal that door.
- (laughing) Yep.
- But a lot of the time, I like forget
that being gay is seen
as the abnormal thing
because it's just like what my life is
and how I love living my life,
and everyone has told me like,
wouldn't it suck if I was straight?
Cause then I wouldn't
have all this like great,
gay sex, like...
(laughing)
- I don't know, like, I'm so creative,
and I love making people laugh.
The whole like creative aspect,
I've opened and let blossom
because I was honest with myself.
- Now that I'm gay, and I
see how fucking great it is,
I would never wish to be straight.
We have so much fun.
Just my day to day life, being gay,
I can listen to whatever music I want,
and it's never a threat to my sexuality.
- You can be whatever you want to be,
compared to things that you can't do
cause maybe that would
be a little too gay.
- How proud I am of this
person that I've become,
and how I feel that I am
the most me I've ever been.
I want that journey for
everyone who is a little gay boy
or gay girl out there who
doesn't feel accepted.
- I'm definitely so much
more comfortable being gay
than I ever have been especially being
in a big city where it's so accepted.
I think that there's still a lot of hate.
A lot of people get gay bashed still,
and we don't always talk about it.
I'm trying to, as a gay
man, become much more active
and talking about that
and putting an end to it.
(ambient techno music)
- I think being gay and
overcoming all the struggles
that we have growing up,
I feel like I'm a lot more empathetic
to different struggles.
Even if it doesn't have anything
to do with being gay, like you can relate.
- A lot of people are so obsessed
with other people's relationships
and like what they're doing
and they're not even
working on their own selves
that for me it was kind
of a step to be like,
"Don't worry about me, like, I'm happy,
I'm genuinely happy, so like
you should be happy to."
It's just more accepting
of like other people
and differences and that it's okay
that we might not agree on something,
even as gay people, cause we're both gay,
but there's probably, we
might have differences
and that it's okay and
we can talk through them.
- Being in the gay community
has taught me a lot
about transparency and acceptance.
Whoever you are, you can
be totally transparent
about who you are and we will accept you.
When you're queer, you have the freedom
to be as masculine or
as feminine as you want.
- I think having anything
that's inherently a part
of who you are that you
have to actively overcome,
growing up, makes you so strong,
and I think that that's
what makes me so proud,
is that I overcame the obstacles
that came along with
being gay, and that led me
to a higher place of self-love,
and that's why I'm so proud of it.
I'm also just really
proud of this community,
and everything that it stands for.
(light techno music)